[Music]
Matt Lauer's double life on TV he was
America's likable dad but behind the
scenes Matt and his wife of 19 years
lived separate lives and has alleged
infidelity with coworkers was well known
today we're learning more about how NBC
has been dealing with the Lauer scandal
an NBC source tells 80 there have been
approximately 60 meetings within NBC
News to share information we're also
told the internal review is only in its
early stages the Today Show held its
holiday party yesterday our source says
it was quote low-key as for who will
replace Lauer well it's getting
interesting he learned this week that
weekend Today Show co-host Craig Melvin
is one of the frontrunners but Hoda Kotb
appears to be gaining traction it's
Friday
since Lauer left and Hoda started
filling in today shot to number one over
GMA and while initially that may have
been due to interest in Lauer's firing
the ratings with Hoda co-hosting
continued to hold up and she'll be back
in Matt's former chair next week in fact
our NBC source tells us Hoda will be in
the co-anchor chair for the foreseeable
future and there's more fallout Lauer
could lose a New Zealand ranch he
recently purchased and reportedly worth
9.2 million dollars here's the issue
New Zealand requires that all foreign
investors must be quote of good
character well in the wake of the claims
against Lauer an official tells ichi
quote we are discussing this with his
representative and are seeking further
information
[Music]
you
[Music]